to formula one though and the Red Bull
Racing team has been dominating the
sport recently last season it
emphatically ended the eight-year streak
of Constructors titles enjoyed by
Mercedes and it's had the top two Podium
finishes in each of the two races so far
this year Well it comes as the
popularity of F1 continues to grow with
the Netflix series drive to survive
pulling in fans from across the globe
well joining me now I'm very pleased to
say is Christian Horner he's the team
principal of the Red Bull formula one
team Christian welcome to you uh
obviously you've made a fantastic start
to the season have we seen the best of
your car yet or is there more to come
we're so early in the season I mean it's
a 23 race calendar we've done two races
in Bahrain and and uh Jeddah so far and
and you know the venues vary a great
deal Australia
um you know just over a week's time so
I'm sure it's gonna ebb and flow but you
know we're hopeful that we can extract
more performance from the car I've seen
some reports suggesting that Mercedes
May tweak their design to bring it
closer in in design to yours I guess
imitation is the best form of flattery
is it yeah absolutely and and you know
the regulations are still relatively
young it's only the second year of these
new regulations so I'm expecting to see
an awful lot of convergence during the
course of the year and the grid is going
to tighten up so uh you know we need to
make sort of hey while the sun shines at
the moment well we've got a competitive
car
and uh yeah I keep just keep pushing
through the season I mean you've won 12
out of the last 13 races do you worry
that your dominance might put some
viewers off
well look I I think that you know some
of the racing has been been fantastic
and I think we saw a great race uh again
at the weekend between our two drivers
and if you do have two dominant cars if
those two cars are racing each other
then I think that does create a
spectacle in itself but I have no doubt
that the opposition are going to be
coming back quickly uh and aggressively
especially as we come back into the
European season where updates start to
come through we're hearing about big
Mercedes upgrades I'm sure Ferrari
aren't happy with their current uh
position as well so you know we're fully
expecting things to converge quickly
once we get back into Europe now you can
win the constructors title only one
driver can win the drivers Championship
how do you manage the two drivers that
you have I mean there's a lot of uh talk
about whether how much they get on well
there's a there's always a conflict
between the two championships so the big
championship for the team is the
constructors that's where the money is
distributed within the sport uh that
comes in through the different uh the
different fees Etc the drivers is the
individual championship and that's the
one that carries this Prestige
especially for the drivers and I think
for us as a team the responsibility is
to give both drivers the same chance the
same opportunity the same car and of
course it's then down to what they do on
the on the circuit we've got two great
drivers uh you know Max and uh and and
Sergio
um there's a healthy respect between the
two of them and uh uh I expect that to
continue
Lewis Hamilton has been very
complementary about uh your car and Toto
wolf your opposite number of Mercedes
said uh he wouldn't blame him if he left
Mercedes could you ever see yourself
signing him
look I think you know what Lewis has
achieved in Formula One is is second to
none but we're you know very happy with
the drivers that that we have
um you know they're committed as a
pastor not only this season but the next
season as well
um so uh yeah I can't see
um where we would be able to accommodate
Lewis but uh I'm sure they're going to
sort their issues out and we're we're
certainly not writing him off yet no
it's six years just about since Liberty
Media bought control of F1 what would
you say has changed in the sport if
anything since I think the biggest thing
is they've brought down the barriers ah
and embrace with digital media
um they've embroidered embraced
initiatives like like Netflix for
example which has been a game changer uh
in the sport bringing things in like the
cost cap to to contain cost and uh you
know adopting a model that is making the
teams effectively franchises
um and that's driven value up and it's
brought an incredible following and a
completely different demo a demographic
you know a lot more girls uh you know
becoming interested in Formula One a lot
more diverse audience and as a result
we're going you know to more and
exciting venues yeah and of course this
big push into the US which has three
races this year I mean how big can this
vote become in the U.S I think the US is
really taken off so you know with the
announcement of the Vegas race we've got
Miami and Austin already we're seeing
massive Brands coming back into the Ford
we're welcoming Ford uh you know as a
partner back in for 2026 with the new
power unit we have Partners like you
know oracle for example we've got five
um you know Fortune 500 companies that
are um you know partners of the team so
we're seeing a great interest we've got
an American driver on the grid now and
uh you know I think that we're just
scratching the surface of what the sport
is is capable of and I think that you
know of course the product's got to be
good but you know the audience that
suddenly woken up to the world of
Formula One not just on track but off
track as well you know is true really
exciting yeah I wanted to ask you about
that partnership with Ford they're going
to be supplying the drivetrain so I mean
how big a deal is this from Ford's
perspective do you think I think it's
it's great for them it's a great
re-entry into the sport they've got a
brand that's synonymous with um you know
with formula one over the years for 2026
you know the the hybridization of the
cars the you know basically it's going
to be 50 electrical power so it fits
their product range with where they're
going with their uh you know their
products for the future and we're not
only seeing Ford coming back in we're
seeing Audi entering the sport and huge
interest from you know from the
manufacturers and I think for us to have
a partnership with a brand like Ford
with a uh the technology that they have
available there's a as a privateer
engine manufacturers it's incredible to
think that Red Bull will be taking on
Mercedes and Ferrari and an Audi but I
think with this partnership with Ford it
fills the missing gaps that we would be
exposed with yeah very exciting
Christian it's great to see you this
morning best of luck for the rest of the
season thank you very much